a pesar del frío y la polución caminan
sin descanso entonando el apellido de su
héroe
rajul Gandhi 52 años El heredero de una
Dinastía política que dirigió la India
durante decenios reconocible la multitud
gracias a su barba y su camiseta Blanca
desde septiembre recorre el país a pie
de Sur a Norte 3600 kilómetros en cinco
meses la caminata comienza todos los
días A las 6 de la mañana rodeado por
miles de simpatizantes durante su
recorrido al ingreso de los pueblos
familias enteras esperan su paso
estamos esperando desde esta mañana no
hemos comido lo que queríamos era verlo
fue tan lindo cuando pasó frente a
nosotros
el desempleo explotó la economía no anda
bien y el país se desmorona es por ello
que nuestra juventud prefiere irse con
esta marcha rajugandi nos envía un
mensaje de Unión y Esperanza hay que
elegir el partido del congreso para
salvar a la India
restablecer la relación con la población
es el objetivo de esta yatra en español
la agrupación por la unidad de la India
una mención disimulada hacia el
principal adversario de Raúl Gandhi el
Primer Ministro nacionalista hindú
narendra modi y su partido de extrema
derecha el bjp en el poder desde 2014
están acusados de dividir al país y
conducir una política de discriminatoria
para con las minorías
contra los que pretenden acallar las
voces de la oposición y propagan el
miedo en nuestro país
aquellos que dividen a la India y crean
tensiones entre las diferentes castas y
las diferentes religiones
marcho contra todo eso
con esta marcha Raúl gandi también
pretende construir una nueva imagen la
de una personalidad política con
credibilidad capaz de gobernar en el
2014 y en el 2019 como sucesor de su
madre Sonia Gandhi conduce la campaña de
las elecciones legislativas el resultado
el partido del Congreso que dominó la
vida política India durante decenios ha
vivido las derrotas más importantes de
su historia frente a los nacionalistas
hindúes llevan casi 10 años en la
oposición pero los miembros del partido
del Congreso creen de nuevo en sus
posibilidades tras cada jornada de
marcha quienes acompañan a rajul Gandhi
desde el primer día pueden descansar en
uno de estos 60 camiones transformados
en dormitorios y todos tienen un
objetivo en mente las próximas
elecciones del 2024
todos los días recibo llamadas de todo
el país de los trabajadores del partido
que quieren unirse a esta marcha que me
preguntan Cómo pueden unirse
a otro fondo nuestros miembros han
despertado y es uno de los éxitos más
significativos de este movimiento y
sobre todo nuestro jefe Raúl Gandhi ha
ganado en altura
su discurso no ha cambiado pero la gente
empieza a considerarlo con Más seriedad
sin embargo estos últimos años numerosos
son los militantes que prefirieron irse
al campo adverso una hemorragia que
parece inatable en Nueva Delhi
hace parte de los últimos en haberlo
hecho tras nueve años en el partido del
Congreso este abogado ante la Corte
Suprema se unió al bjp como portavoz en
diciembre Esta foto es interesante Aquí
hay varios amigos que abandonaron casi
todos el congreso para adherir al Pep JP
Este es el señor es India quien ahora es
ministro de la Aviación no me avergüenzo
de mi pasado político Cuando miro estas
fotografías me siento triste porque uno
de los partidos políticos más en el
mundo se está descarrilando ya no tiene
visión para él El Congreso se volvió una
formación política dinástica cerrada
desde el interior
la alta jerarquía está inmunizada Frente
a cualquier tipo de crítica
son alérgicos a toda propuesta de
reforma hay una estrategia siniestra en
el partido del congreso para garantizar
que su Estado Mayor viva protegido
un partido muy centralizado y que no
logra deshacerse de los escándalos que
afectaron su último mandato entre 2009 y
2014 para este analista político si el
congreso desea ganar de nuevo tendrá que
proponer un programa que pueda seducir a
sus electores pasados para vencer al bjp
debe volver a buscar al pueblo con un
programa es en ello que el bjp es muy
diferente el bjp también es muy
centralizado en su manera de manejar el
partido y el gobierno pero mantuvieron
el contacto con sus ejecutivos con su
base en el terreno Y si usted Mira las
políticas puestas en marcha se dirigen a
las diferentes castas a las diferentes
comunidades del país escuchan los
problemas y tratan de solucionar en
especial con una política social muy
fuerte súmele a eso su agenda sobre la
Innova que consiste en clamar la
grandeza del hinduismo que seduce a las
masas ellos le da una ventaja
considerable al bjp sobre el congreso
antes de las elecciones legislativas de
2024 9 escrutinios regionales deben
tener lugares este año en el país una
prueba mayor para el congreso Si desea
seguir siendo un partido de envergadura
nacional